hey Dylan McDermott here I'm with
BuzzFeed and we are doing a thirst
tweets I'm a little scared here we go mm
another practice turned me gay and dylan
mcdermott on American Horror Story kept
me gay you're welcome
Dillard Dermot is the reason I have a
daddy complex yeah get in line
I still get confused between Dermot
Mulroney and Dylan McDermott if they
were in a movie together my head would
explode from sexy confusion yes well you
know that we actually did LA to Vegas
together the co-star was very generous
to come on and co-star and we had a
blast he is a sweetheart and we laughed
and laughed laughs there's so much
confusion so many years of confusion
30-plus years of computing
I'm so confused at this point sometimes
I I go out and I look at my license
and it says Dermot Mulroney I made my
mom watch American Horror Story from the
beginning and she goes if you told me I
get to see Dylan McDermott's but I would
have watched sooner yeah I get that a
lot but thank you so much mom
appreciate it decided to watch American
Horror Story for the first time but it's
hard to focus with Dylan McDermott he's
on screen and like his whole ass Neal
well here we go again we got to ass
tweets thank you again hard to focus
with the ass mule I've never actually
heard asked meal before so thank you for
that thing I'm gonna use that a little
bit throw that around the quarantine
house I want to outline dylan mcdermott
ads with my tongue okay all right Lisa's
not my ass how much do I have to pay at
dylan mcdermott to run me over with a
truck nothing I would get on my knees
hmm so damn quickly whoo these are
getting hotter for Dylan McDermott Jesus
Christ he's so damn hot
[Laughter]
thank you I guess muchas gracias
Dylan McDermott sexy white ass if he
could hold me hostage any day another
ass tweet that's three now calculating
here for up to three yes I want Dylan
McDermott smothered want him covered
like my Waffle House hashbrowns Oh hash
browns okay
my husband just told me he is gay but
one man and that man is that Dylan
McDermott I'm not even mad I completely
get it it's nice
I wish Santa would give me Dylan
McDermott for a daddy
Wow what is it April man still time
Dylan McDermott could spit in my face
and call me whatever he wanted Dylan
McDermott owns this buzzy what tell me
what a bus is it's a-okay all right let
me try it again then knowing that
information
whoo doesn't make joint owns the
McDermott owns Dylan McDermott owns this
bus II took off my jacket novice this is
getting crazy next I would let Dylan
McDermott ruin my Bucci I hope my mom
never sees this tweet damn it I have to
have a translation of Buchi Wow I really
wanted to learn McDermott to rage beat
me on the tennis court and then hey win
me in the locker room afterwards don't I
we're just gonna move on from that one I
hope when my penis gets older he stays
good-looking in shape and has silky
black hair because I basically want to
be I don't know charlie that's really
nice of you to say that's wait I'm going
to take a shower and congratulate myself
and I want to thank BuzzFeed for having
me and Hollywood it's a great show guys
and I can't wait for you watching
[Music]
[Music]